ton cauchemar il commence dès la porte
d'entrée de l'immeuble c'est tout sauf
pour les personnes dans votre situation
avec une pente devant la porte regardez
on se fixera des objectifs à mobilité
réduite là-bas au bout des couloirs il y
aura de la lumière à capter on va tenter
d'aller la voir avec un espoir adapté
[Musique]
ça arrive également que des pannes
d'ascenseur forcément et là c'est
terrible comment tu fais et si tu veux
que je te dise
je vais devoir glisser dans les
escaliers comme il n'y a pas d'ascenseur
donc je vais devoir avec ma jambe qui
fonctionne
comme ça super
donc c'est assez incroyable comment tu
fais en fait après quand il y a pas
d'ascenseur
tu peux descendre tu fais quoi avec ton
fauteuil en fait je peux pas utiliser
mon fauteuil
parce que il pouvait pas me transporter
parce que ma colonne est quand même
assez fragile donc le risque était trop
grand donc ça a été entre guillemets la
meilleure solution pour prendre le
moindre risque possible et donc ouais
donc tu as été descendu et après quoi
après quand tu es revenu l'ascenseur il
a marché ou bien ils ont dû te monter on
avait prévu d'aller à l'hôtel parce que
je pouvais pas repartir et il y a une
intervention d'urgence à ce moment-là il
y a eu au moins 10 pannes depuis un an
donc
au troisième
alors une fois dans ton appartement la
seule chose qu'on peut voir c'est que
rien n'est fait pour une personne
handicapée tu loues ton appartement
depuis combien de temps là-bas ça fait
un an et demi et
ça fait un logement adapté avec mon
bailleur 3F comment tu payes pour moi
700 euros
regardez regardez la salle de bain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y a déjà ce qui devrait être
complètement anodin qui se transforme
aussi en véritable épreuve pour Nabila
comme le simple fait d'ouvrir une
fenêtre regardez
il n'est pas si simple d'ouvrir et de
fermer une fenêtre quand on est en
situation de handicap ici dans le salon
la fenêtre est assez grande mais le
salon étant étroit je ne peux pas
accéder à cette fenêtre car les meubles
me gênent bon peut-être que je vais me
rabattre sur celle de la cuisine qui
donne sur un petit balcon je tente c'est
pas extra mais ça s'ouvre quand même un
petit peu oui le balcon n'est pas
accessible il y a une marche et oui il
fallait y penser à ça on tente dans ma
chambre qui normalement est une chambre
adaptée au PMR mais ils ont pas bien
pensé le cercle de rotation
c'est incroyable alors dernière vidéo en
plus d'appartement et malheureusement
toute la ville qui n'est pas adaptée
regardez
en prenant au hasard une route Paris on
s'aperçoit très vite que celle-ci ne
sont pas accessibles mais que même les
immeubles ne le sont pas donc des
appartements qui ne peuvent pas être
loués à des personnes à mobilité réduite
on peut s'apercevoir qu'il y a des
marches bien trop hautes pour un
fauteuil roulant électrique ceci est un
vrai parcours du combattant pour les
personnes en situation de handicap il
reste quoi pour nous les voies de garage
Nabila donc merci d'être avec nous
chaque pièce est problématique pour vous
le quotidien est un enfer
comment vous mettez au lit
en fait mon fauteuil ne peut pas
atteindre la chambre d'accord donc je
suis obligée de l'abandonner dans le
couloir et après je dois en paix
donc tous les soirs
et le matin vous réveillez vous rampez
jusqu'à exactement j'ai entre guillemets
la chance d'avoir ma partie gauche qui
est saine donc je pousse avec ma jambe
gauche pour atteindre mon lit et à la
force du bras vous avez été victime d'un
accident il y a 8 ans je le rappelle
c'est un accident de j'étais victime
d'un accident de voiture et donc vous
avez été paralysé de tout un côté de
toute la partie droite donc je dois être
un fauteuil électrique obligatoirement
puisque mon bailleur m'a dit mais
changer de fauteuil mais pour un
fauteuil manuel il faut les deux bras
pour pousser les roues donc c'est
absolument pas la manette exactement
donc pour aller aux toilettes aussi
c'est un enfer
en fait toutes les pièces sont
inaccessibles parce que pour pouvoir
utiliser mon fauteuil il faudrait que je
puisse tourner avec l'utiliser il faut
de l'espace et cet espace là je ne l'ai
pas puisque la norme c'est 1,50 mon
fauteuil c'est un 70 eux ils ont un 30
d'accord ils sont même pas dans la norme
comment vous avez fait pour louer cet
appartement à la base moi j'étais déjà
en fait dans ce avec ce bailleur
puisqu'ils avaient racheté mon immeuble
qui était dans le privé tout simplement
et en fait au bout de six mois quand on
a su que mon état n'allait pas du tout
allait mieux je les ai informés de ma
situation de handicap ils m'ont déplacé
dans un premier logement avec le logo
PMR c'était parfait et une fois arrivé
sur place je me suis rendu compte que je
ne pouvais même pas sortir de chez moi
donc je suis restée deux ans enfermée
pour vous laver on imagine c'est aussi
compliqué vous avez tout le monde tout
le temps peur de tomber le bailleur a
été interrogé il affirme qu'ils ont tout
fait pour améliorer votre logement et
qu'ils ont notamment fait 100000 euros
de travaux qu'est-ce que vous dites à ça
moi ils me disent depuis 7 ans quoi 8
ans maintenant qu'ils sont très
mobilisés je veux bien les croire mais 8
ans c'est long de mobilisation donc il y
a un moment peut-être que la personne
qui se charge du dossier a un souci sur
la compréhension du handicap je peux
l'entendre mais 100000 euros très
honnêtement si cet appartement a eu
100.000 euros de travaux moi qui me
laisse les gérer les travaux parce que
vous avez pas contacté vous avez fait
constater les manquements par un
huissier oui parce que quand j'ai
constaté que il y avait un souci pour
pas qu'il pense que c'était un caprice
ou que je négociais des choses j'ai fait
appel à un huissier qui était à côté de
chez moi pour qu'il constate et qu'ils
se voir qu'en fait il y avait pas
d'accessibilité au logement alors votre
bailleur ne trouve aucune bonne solution
qu'est-ce que vous avez proposé
j'ai interpellé beaucoup notamment les
élus de ma ville la Mairie du 15e qui a
vraiment tout fait ils ont suivi le
dossier ils ont appelé tous les 15 jours
madame Ferrat qu'elle est lui en
handicap était exceptionnelle mais le
problème c'est qu'ils disent toujours
oui mais il ne se passe rien on va s'en
occuper ça fait combien de temps que ça
dure qu'ils disent oui ça fait 8 ans
oui au bout de 8 ans ouais ça y est
c'est un problème et vous ont proposé
d'autres appartements alors il m'avait
proposé un appartement avant celui-ci
qui n'était pas adapté il fallait passer
par les
sous rentrer chez moi j'avais pas accès
à la porte principale donc un petit peu
comme un rat il fallait que je passe et
que je grimpe chez moi voilà ne parlez
pas de rails
donc à chaque fois ça correspondait pas
à votre situation
vous avez l'impression d'avoir été
complètement laissé tomber c'est ça j'ai
l'impression qu'en fait
[Musique]
bon comme d'autres personnes qui peuvent
être malades pour savoir on m'a percuté
en fait on m'a percuté mon véhicule et
ça a suffi pour que ce soit
j'étais conductrice le traité conducteur
il a perdu le contrôle et ça a suffi en
quelques instants en fait ça peut tous
nous arriver bien sûr quoi moi j'avais
une carrière j'étais parti travailler à
la Réunion j'étais très heureuse dans ma
vie donc tout allait bien
ce qui est dramatique c'est que moi j'ai
très vite accepté mon handicap
je voulais dire et vous voilà vous vous
demandez vous vous voilà vous vous
acceptez votre handicap vous êtes vous
êtes heureuse et voilà je vous ai dit
tout à l'heure à la pub je vous ai dit
je trouve magnifique non mais c'est vrai
et et aujourd'hui vous vous retrouvez
dans une situation qui vous oblige à
entamer une greffe de la fin parce que
ça ne bouge pas ça fait 8 ans que vous
dit on va bouger et ça ne bouge pas et
un moment vous êtes dit ben la seule
chose que je vais faire pour qu'on
puisse parler de moi c'est peut-être
médiatiser l'affaire et peut-être
médiatiser l'affaire en faisant
peut-être aussi une grève de la fin
c'est ce que je me suis dit voilà et
peut-être sensibiliser les gens parce
qu'il y a d'autres gens aussi qui sont
certainement dans votre cas il y en a
énormément je le sais et donc pour que
ça puisse bouger c'est la seule solution
à vos yeux oui parce que je suis remonté
jusqu'à au ministère du handicap et du
logement et même à la présidence et on
dit que on ne peut rien faire on ne peut
pas agir sur les bailleurs et le
bailleur 3F ne répond même pas parfois
donc je ne vois pas d'autres solutions
et un appartement en rez-de-chaussée
avait sans obstacle du tout et dans
lequel tu peux tourner
ça fait combien de temps que tu fais des
ingrédients
là je l'ai commencé aujourd'hui en fait
je leur ai laissé du temps qui
réagissent et je commencer en alertant
en leur disant réagissez avant que ce
soit trop grave parce que évidemment
j'ai des traitements très lourds donc ça
va être très violent mais il y a un
moment je suis pas la seule dans cette
situation là on est complètement
invisibilisé il y a un moment stop on
demande nos droits on n'a pas à supplier
un bailleur social qui doit faire du
social pour avoir un logement et il
parle d'argent alors qu'on parle de vie
en fait donc je comprends pas ça peut
vous mettre dans une situation encore
plus compliquée parce que on sait que
parfois c'est c'est là vous faites mal à
vous voilà c'est c'est vous et vous
allez j'ai peur qu'il y a des séquelles
le mine de rien qui qui soit importante
s'il est agréable de la faim se prolonge
en plus vous l'avez dit il faut quand
même de la force pour ramper pour
essayer de vivre au jour le jour
n'est pas peur de de ça
Cyril chez moi je vais un cauchemar je
nombre de chutes un calculable j'ai même
fait un départ de feu parce que j'ai pas
réussi à gérer ce qui se passait vu que
j'étais pas sûrement fauteuil soit un
jour je tombe chez moi et on me découvre
dans trois jours ou quatre jours soit
j'agis et je maîtrise encore un peu la
situation à travers cette grève de la
fin et je la fais aussi pour toutes les
personnes dans la même situation que moi
qui sont encore plus faibles et qui
peuvent pas la faire peut-être que si
mon bailleur réagit et qu'on dit que
faut que ça s'arrête et qu'on change la
loi et qu'ils aient une obligation de
relogement peut-être qu'à ce moment-là
on sera plus invisibilisé qu'on sera
tous entendu et vous disent quoi vos
proches
ils comprennent en fait
on va venir t'aider on va venir à la
maison
chaque soir il y a un proche qui est là
pour m'aider pour me mais voilà j'ai mon
envie
déjà une auxiliaire de vie c'est pas
toujours évident même si elles sont
adorables mais en plus solliciter
constamment la famille il y a un moment
moi je paie un loyer j'ai demandé depuis
le début un logement adapté il savait
que c'était un fauteuil roulant
électrique ils m'ont fourni des plans
qui correspondaient et puis la réalité
ne le correspond plus
il y a un moment faut que on arrête ça
et qu'il prenne une vraie position ils
ont voulu à qui aujourd'hui j'en veux à
personne
même pas parce que je me dis il y a un
moment on les laisse faire donc si on
laisse les personnes et qu'on leur dit
qu'il y aura jamais de sanction bah ils
s'engouffre dedans donc il faut
absolument que la loi encore une fois
change pour que ils aient des sanctions
quand ils agissent comme ça aujourd'hui
vous êtes vous êtes à bout oui je suis é
si je le fais maintenant c'est parce que
je sais que je ne tiendrai pas cet été
quoi un été sans pouvoir se doucher sans
ouvrir ses fenêtres avec la canicule en
rampant je suis pas un animal j'ai droit
à avoir de la dignité j'ai cette
maltraitance là c'est pour moi c'est de
la maltraitance donc après je suis dans
le combat j'ai un mental qui est fort
mais combien de personnes auraient
peut-être mis fin à leur vie dans le
silence sans qu'on sache qu'il s'est
passé derrière
on peut pas tolérer ça parce que souvent
en plus c'est souvent des femmes en
situation de handicap donc elles sont
souvent agressées et en plus on rajoute
la maltraitance administrative non vous
redoutez de rentrer chez vous ce soir
alors déjà faut que l'ascenseur
fonctionne première étape et après c'est
voilà c'est de nouveau rentrer dans
l'endroit qui me fait tant souffrir qui
me prive de tout tu me prive de douche
qui me prive de pouvoir me nourrir
correctement
c'est épuisant c'est épuisant c'est
grève de la fin donc vous avez compté ne
pas l'arrêter tant qu'ils n'ont pas
trouvé une solution
qu'on me transportait à l'hôpital parce
que je serai beaucoup beaucoup trop
faible mais j'irai jusqu'au bout et je
pense qu'ils ne connaissent assez pour
savoir que j'irai jusqu'au bout il y a
pas vos poches qui vous disent tu vas
pas faire ça on compte sur toi on a
besoin de toi mais bien sûr qu'ils ont
peur pour moi en fait ça impacte toutes
mes proches mes amis ma famille mais on
fait quoi d'autre pour vous il y a quand
même d'arriver à cette solution mais si
le ministère ne peut pas agir
si le Défenseur des droits ne peut pas
agir si le préfet ne peut pas agir
je fais appel à qui
à vous merci on va essayer Nabilla de
faire bouger les choses assez vite parce
que on veut pas que vous se retrouver
dans une situation de santé qui soit
très problématique et qui voilà qui sont
irréversible et on n'a pas envie de ça
et vraiment on vous voit moi je vous
vois aujourd'hui vous êtes je vous l'ai
dit encore je vous le redis encore vous
êtes magnifique ou vraiment vous je
voilà je suis un coup de cœur pour vous
même à la pub vraiment je vous le dis et
comme elle l'a dit elle a accepté son
accident la belle a accepté son handicap
elle veut juste pouvoir vivre décemment
avec son handicap et pouvoir voilà elle
demande pas un truc de fou et voilà donc
j'espère que ça va se régler et on va
essayer de tout faire aussi de notre
côté pour que cet été vous puissiez
vivre dignement correctement et que vous
puissiez arrêter votre navigation au
plus vite des la des ce week-end parce
que vous voudrez pas que ça ça se
prolonge